div mme ans je la vois comme changer je
l'avoué je le vois ça va aller la
sexualité est un sujet déjà tabou dans
notre société alors l'onco sexualité
entendez par là la sexualité des
personnes atteintes du cancer est un
sujet encore plus délicat selon les
membres de l'association à tout mot qui
organisait une journée découverte
aujourd'hui il faut d'abord se dire que
sexualité ne veut pas forcément dire
acte sexuel c'est difficile quand on a
tous les traitements avec des fois des
traitements qui sont longs qui ont des
effets secondaires qui peuvent être
assez invalidant donc avec ça
aujourd'hui on fait quoi donc nous on
tourne autour du bien-être on est
capable de se réapproprier son camp par
les soins socio esthétique par le
toucher massage par la réflexologie les
psychologues on vient derrière pour
justement l'image du coran qui est
perturbé aujourd'hui avec ça je fais
quoi
quels outils j'ai aujourd'hui les
psychologues ont m comment on vous aide
avec vos outils vous avez ça c'est votre
personne en globalité et non vous
apprend à ont retrouvé la personne que
vous êtes j'ai une mastectomie
et concernant la sexualité en fait c'est
un peu difficile mais d'après ce qu'ils
montrent l on dit moi j'ai bien compris
que c'était par rapport à ce que ce
qu'ils avaient déjà dans le couple alors
c'est vrai qu'on essaie de d'arranger
les choses de faire de manière à ce que
que ça arrive quand je suis un petit peu
plus en état mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas souvent c'est pas ça parce que je
suis toujours très thiviers la toute
jeune association atoumo créée en avril
dernier soit agir sur les soins de
support pour diminuer les effets
secondaires des traitements et les
inconvénients de la maladie pour une
meilleure qualité de vie des patients et
de leurs proches
les soignants des soins dans benno
beaucoup en plus de notre travail
mesvres on vivre pour les patients pour
promouvoir les soins de confort et de
montres et d'accompagnement autres
années à faire avec les patients avec de
concert avec les patients pour leur
faire comprendre que oui effectivement
là et cette difficulté en cinématique
dans l'est au sein des couples au sein
des familles mais que ce n'est pas une
fin en soi et qu'on peut se reconstruire
pour le moment un tout mot compte huit
membres dont trois permanents tous
persuadés que c'est par l' approche
globale de la personne malade qu'on peut
accroître ses chances de terrasser le
cancer et de retrouver une bonne qualité
de vie